yeah hello and welcome to this blitz
video what am I going to do when I have
three I really don't know anything else
I gone idea three spiders step nose okay
let's go probably to a king's indian you
can still play yeah something offbeat
ish like this all right now again that's
it not since we cannot be wrong I think
this is good but it's been a long time
since I had a look at this night h6 I
believe is what they do okay that's
certainly possible it's a bit on the
slow side I mean black is not unhappy in
many cases that his bishop is gone the
bishop is not that great often on g7 but
hmm we shouldn't forget that this is not
a totally close structure yet I still
have ideas to open up ok so what he
probably wants to do is to take here and
then gain access but I can go here right
I can do this Bishop 03 @ x e6 that
wouldn't be a good idea
night to be four okay so i probably have
to cover the fork on c2 and the Queen
moves would be more natural looking at
windy to it then he'll take him c5 ok
let's UK by vitac you will probably take
with the night and have some play on
with the 94 coming and yeah I think I'm
just going to keep the position closed
there's nothing particularly wrong with
that I still have more space iam yeah
let's move at all about and I wonder if
Queen age 6 is an idea but he has Bishop
f3 after which I don't want to take with
the pawn which yeah let's be a bit
uncomfortable but maybe i can send the
night back first and now play Queen h6
yeah this looks a little bit annoying
here for black
ah maybe I could have played 95
immediately huh that's something that I
should have thought about 95 Bishop e2
96 it would have been interesting but
it's an interesting thing to keep in
mind so like if he goes King f7 I have
95 check even and the bush appears
hanging this is a problem because tf7 is
kind of the movie would like to play now
as Queen g7 looks gap quite irritating
and hear ya again I can probably play
Queen g7 what is he going to do after
that no am i winning a porn or something
I think I do
I don't really see a good movie fam I
don't know yeah yeah but he i'm gay i'm
getting f6 that's even worse than losing
any other pawn here because without the
f porn he has no no particular play
[Music]
let's check 95 s not yet on now gt5
though would be quite good it's one of
the good moves and one of the good moves
let's go now g5 come you might take it
to action hmm it's not the end of the
world but ok let's do it i'm not quite
sure if this is really best but can
hardly be bad
I can actually take you seven here in
this case so check this is what I have
planned just just play the ending here
with a clean extra pawn um yeah but
still how to do it yeah probably like
that I don't even know if night is six
is that effect of him you can always
trade it off with 9790 h3 is probably
better so let's go here threatening
Knight g4 I'm just on the side so was
kind of helpful ever have some threats
in addition to a nice strategic
advantage II pre-empting his be five so
i can just take and take the be foul he
cannot take with the deep on 93 is too
terrible so probably whooped ub6 end
like this is it looks pretty nice you
cannot oppose on the beef are all that
easily
so how'd you how to do something here
something effective and I think that
this should connect you to the f5 square
somehow 1c3 it's literally doing nothing
yeah see now i'm off to f5 you will
probably play this back mmm so nice here
for night f6 or potentially this so that
it will get a 5 ultimately it should be
pretty much decisive you can also take
1d6 there's something wrong with it I
don't see it check check check yeah
there's also no trapping of the night
it's not him not going to work black
resigns okay so i think that was a
pretty uncomfortable position out of the
opening him we can have a look here with
the engine i think this is normal but
they I think people usually go night h6
in this situation here I'm not
completely sure it's been a while since
I check this yeah I think something like
this is kind of okay prob like it wasn't
that Carlton you well okay Bishop h6 I
don't know how bad this can be at it
cannot be terrible i think so night
Bishop g4 I'm not sure about this move
to be honest because after d5 black does
not really have a move that he loves to
play there's an ad before a business
that you play that also loses quite a
bit of time and no yeah this is not
happening I'm taking here of course it
can also go back I'm not sure 92 is
given by the engine I'm not sure if I
would have played that Bishop e2 also
doesn't look bad this is sensible asked
black about his next move which is not
so easy to play because he's kind of
tangled up him and I it's a better
position for one okay so we had this and
I think yeah taking does not convince
because here he has some chance of using
the square i played this that that's
something you can argue about I mean
something like 92 also makes quite some
sense just let this basically yeah it
tests no it doesn't make any sense on
g-force when I'm trying to say and
oftentimes black
just have to lose more time but like
retreating until what the engine is
giving here some f four bases play it's
not unreasonable yeah okay and I don't
think that this was particularly bad and
the computer is already very pessimistic
about black it wants to take em and play
king of Selma that's pretty dreadful
alright if you have to play into this
position something has gone wrong no but
this is essentially winning I think 95
yeah I expected him to take on each who
actually and King takes hmm King takes I
thought I thought could you fall back
the annoying but it doesn't really help
damn this is hanging yeah look f8 this
is just leading to a check disastrous
ending I could have taken on age 70 I
completely overlooked it that would have
been a lot easier actually I mean this
is also good enough to win the game but
just grab another one cut out hood and
now I think that was a decent plan
getting the night over to to have five
Jim Backus essentially falling apart
well that's an interesting check
interesting engine line leads to a
fantastic poem roller but this is also
more or less chatting yeah those are
those d6 g6 systems i always do with a
little bit of a suspicion of plate
demeanor was the kid but nowadays i feel
that wine mostly gets a good Kings
Indian ok guys thanks for watching